brace yourselves we have a cookie idea
here today Florence hello how are you
doing hi hi how you doing I hope the
creative juices are flowing today
because we are going to task you with
casting all of the collider pets in
movies okay here we go do I believe the
first one up
is APA
I reckon Apple would have to be Dobby
for obvious reasons because he's cute
and small has big ears that is a very
spot-on comparison yeah you looked quite
shocked when I first said that but I I
stand by that I think I'm surprised I
hadn't noticed that oh I see very very
spot on though thank you all right next
up we have the gorgeous Missy
oh oh oh I know it would have to be
um Bigfoot from Monsters Inc oh
yeah or eats snow cones questionable
snow cones yeah all right next up this
is a high pressure one this is Malcolm
I mean just by the half white half black
it has to be Cruella Deville no this is
my baby and I feel personally insulted
by it oh no I love gorilla DeVille no I
love Corella I love Corella I don't love
what she's about no I suppose but maybe
this is like Cruella for dogs we're
we're Switching gears we're going with
with Echo the gerbil
I'm looking at the nose it's quite a
Squidward nose so maybe it's a bit of a
Squidward this next one
is Pom-Pom whoa
that's quite a face I thought that'd be
the reaction to Pom-Pom oh my goodness
there's a bit of like an Idris Elba
seriousness stair going on there I feel
like that's the highest compliment any
of our pets have gotten today we are up
to Cinnamon the dog
oh I think cinnamon is definitely Steve
Carell in anything he just has the most
adorable kind looking face like we would
do no bad and I feel like that way with
Steve Carell oh this is a good one
number seven is Rex
I used my Dobby because you look very
similar to Dobby actually this is like
Darby's cousin this is Dobby's cousin
I'm gonna say Dobby's cousin we're up to
number eight this is Pebbles oh my God
he's Bruce from Matilda Brucie number
nine is Turtles the turtle
what about the eagle from The Rescuers
oh I've not thought of that movie in
forever I know great movie number 10 is
Cobalt
oh you're definitely Chewbacca okay I'll
roll with you back on this one here is
number 11. this is sandwich the cat
Captain Hook baby because of the knife I
think that's correct Captain Hook we are
on to another cat this is Gollum
oh I wouldn't say he looks like a Golem
I said the same exact thing when I was
sent this photo I think not looks like
Devil Wears Prada Priestly the Meryl
Streep of cats yet another very high
compliment here all right we are up to
dash the dog
I'm getting like slight Napoleon
Dynamite Vibes sweet I don't know why I
bet he can bust the moves this is Chloe
the dog very sleepy sleepy bunny like a
snow white maybe because she's always
sleepy and she's very white there all
right this right here is Billy the cat
it was very sleek and slender that's
like a James Bond character wow yeah I'd
say that's a James Bond let's go to go
to Wally but look at that snout the
snout is making me think maybe some sort
of like ant anteater animation but I've
never seen a cute anteater animation so
I don't want to say that
maybe we can make a character for him
while he is a one of a kind yeah exactly
that makes a lot of yeah he's his own
story he's his own character he is named
after Wally like the Pixar character
that's one of my favorite movies he has
actually a bit like Wally let's wrap
with Loki and Bandit
that's very like lady in the [ __ ]
actually Lady and the [ __ ] that's my my
final answer all right lock it in I love
it
thank you thank you for your patience
and for jumping into the zany idea with
us Puss in Boots The Last Wish
is exceptional I've just had my
expectations blown it's a beautiful
movie I love the story huge
congratulations thank you so much have a
lovely day